[AUDIO LOGO]
- Hey, everybody. Welcome
to the Data Science Hangout
and our last Data
Science Hangout of 2023.
I know people always say this,
but seriously can't believe that
we're already here at the
end of the year.
I want to say a huge
thank you to the 47
leaders who have joined us at
the Data Science Hangout this year.
CO-HOST: Thank you,
Rachael, for hosting.
- Thank you.
And those three sessions where
we all were the featured leaders.
And
who knows if this is
accurate with Zoom, but
the over 2,600
people who have joined us
at Data Science Hangouts since
we've started them
and the core group here
who keeps coming back and hanging
out with us each week.
So thank you all so much
for making this space what it is.
I really love getting to
spend time with you all.
If this is your first
time joining us today,
it's so nice to meet
you. I'm Rachael.
I lead customer
marketing at Posit.
If it is your first hangout,
say hi to us in the chat
because we'd love to welcome
you in as well.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
So we're here together every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
We'll be on a bit of a
holiday break here for the next few
weeks. But we'll be
back on January 11.
So if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later and
want to add it
to your calendar,
it will be in the details below
on how you can join us live.
We're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody.
So we love hearing from
everyone no matter your years
of experience, titles, languages
you work in or
industries. And it's totally
OK to just listen in here if
you're out walking your dog,
if you're in a coffee
shop or something.
But there's always three
ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own perspective
on certain topics. So you can
raise your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep my eye out.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat
and just put a little star next
to it if it's something you
want me to read
out loud instead.
And then we also have a
Slido link, where you can ask
questions anonymously,
and we'll share that
in the chat here
in just a second.
And I love
Mike's suggestion in the chat
here to get everybody going
because we love the
conversation that happens in
the chat. But share your
favorite holiday film in there.
I'm taking Mike's suggestion
from there. Pfizer
hangout too.
But with that, I'm so excited
to be joined by my co-host
today, Sean
Nguyen, senior staff data scientist
at S2G Ventures. And, Sean,
I'd love to have you jump
in here and introduce yourself and
share a little bit
about your role,
but also something you like
to do outside of work too.
- Yeah. So I'm Sean. I'm a
first data science hire at S2G Ventures.
We're a venture capital-based
company based in Chicago.
We're investing in food
and oceans and clean energy
companies. And so we were
founded in 2017. And I was
brought on
in 2021 as the first data
science hire to flesh out the
capabilities of
the organization.
And my background is
in molecular biology.
And so
I was really interested
in working in data.
And then I learned about this
thing called data science.
And then I got really
addicted to learning how to program.
And then I kind of took those
skills and took it to S2G.
And then in terms of things that
I like to do outside of work,
I really like photography and
cooking. So I'm a bit of a
person that likes to try
out new restaurants in Chicago and
cook at home. So yeah.
- What's one of your
favorite things, to cook?
- I like to cook
different cuisines like--
I don't know. It depends
what I'm feeling.
So sometimes I'll create
Thai curry paste
from scratch, right,
and just kind of make that
and use it for different things. So
like trying different cuisines.
So yeah.
- Well,
I get to start off with some
of the questions here as we wait
for them to come in
from everybody. But
I just wanted to say I loved
your Posit Comp Talk from this year.
And
was just listening to it a
few days ago. But I love when
you spoke a bit about the PoC
or proof of concept that you did.
And I thought it might be
helpful to start by talking a
little bit about that,
so we can all get some context
into some of the work that you do.
Would you be able to explain
a bit about the project that you
came up with to use for
your PoC and kind of get buy-in
across the company for your project?
- Yeah. So
as the first data science hire within
the org, I knew we wanted to
get information to our
business units, right? And so
what I wanted to do was
run analysis and send it to, let's
say, my manager, right?
The thing is that when I
created an R Markdown document
at the time in order to
share it with her, I had to
basically render the HTML file,
and send it over
because I didn't have a
server. Because it's
proprietary information,
we can't share it easily.
Because you don't want
it out in the world.
So I'd send the
email attachment and
send it to her, and then she
would be like, Oh, this is great.
But I don't want to download
something and have to open it.
So I'd want be able
to click a URL link.
And so in terms of what it was,
what it was it's kind of an
analysis of anything that she
wanted to know that's perfect for
her job. So let's say,
like here's a meetings that
you have during the week,
and then it's really insightful
information that you can't
necessarily get
from, let's say, a--
like a dashboard or
something like that.
It's super specific to them.
So like in terms of the idea
of the PoCs that is to kind of
almost give that nugget
of like, Oh, wow,
this is really useful to me,
and then being able to
surface that to them.
And then what that does is
it gets that buy in because
oftentimes, when you're
trying to, let's say,
get a new service
or a new product,
some people will look at the
sticker price, it's like, oh, sticker shock.
It's like, oh, wow, there's
no way I'm going to pay that.
We already have Tableau. We
already have Power BI, whatever.
Why do I want to get another
data science product I've never heard of?
So in order to almost
get the buy in, is you kind
of give them that, oh, wow, sure,
the art of the possible
to be like, oh, you know,
here's this cool thing I was
able to do. And then they're
like, oh, my gosh, I really
like that. Tell me more.
And then that's how you can kind
of get them to be like, oh,
this is really useful because
you kind of are surfacing
information that's really
relevant to them at that time.
Right? So--
- Yeah.
And I think that's something that's
come up quite a bit on
the Hangouts, too,
which might be good to chat
a little bit more about is the
communication piece of
your insights, but also
realizing you might need to
have some different approaches,
like not everybody is going to
go and look at a dashboard.
They might need a summary
of insights in an email.
SEAN: Yeah.
-
And I'm wondering what lessons
have you learned about that
communication piece.
- Yeah. So I think the
idea of being able to proactively find
information that might
be relevant to people,
because like to your point,
I can create 10 dashboards,
and then just be like,
oh, check the dashboards. Other
people, they don't have
time to do that, right?
And so sometimes
you can be like, oh,
it looks like you're
meeting with Mary
from whatever company. Did you
know that XYZ thing happened, right?
And then they can go armed,
ready with this knowledge
whenever they meet with this
individual. And they don't
have to check a dashboard.
And so being able to find
whatever information,
whether it be from a
different data source, or some analysis,
or report, and then you're able
to send them an email, right?
Or some type
of alert dynamically, right?
So I use the blastula package
within R to kind of send emails
programmatically to people.
And so that's how I was able
to get them to really latch on to
that. Because to your point,
people don't want to
necessarily have to check
something, right?
It'd be nice if it was
delivered to you in your inbox.
And you can be like, oh,
wow, this is really helpful.
And then you go on your way.
- [INAUDIBLE]
shared into the chat the
example that you referenced in
your talk.
But Kelly O'Brien at
Posit built this example,
where she had like a
cookie cutter, Etsy shop.
And she showed how she
used blastula and Posit Connect to
send out these conditional
emails. It's just a fun
example. I wanted to
share in the chat, too.
SEAN: Oh, yeah. It's great.
- And I'm seeing
a lot of love for
blastula here [CHUCKLES]
in the chat as well. So
feel free to share some--
oh, I think you already are--
share some resources on
that, too. Thanks, Marcos.
George, I see you asked
a question here in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
I know it's a question kind
of for the chat as well.
But I thought it would be
good to discuss live, too.
GEORGE: Sure, yeah.
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, that got me
thinking about just prior
roles that I had.
And I was wondering if anyone
else had a prior job in sales.
And I think the way you put
it, Sean, where you said
the person might ask, you
know, I already have this.
I already have that. Why
do I need this new thing?
I'm like, that's exactly
like the kind of
sales question and
interaction that I used
to have in a prior role.
But I never really
thought about bringing those skills
here because I was never really
good at it. It's not like my
natural state to
try and sell things.
So just wondering if there's
any best practices that maybe
people have in general
from being in a sales role.
Maybe you sold cell
phones, maybe you sold
cars, I don't know.
But it seems like it's very
important in what we do.
- Yeah. I mean I don't
have experience in sales.
But I think to your point,
I think it's about
trying to find that
the way that you
can provide value.
I feel like I'm
reiterating my talk, sorry.
So to find value that the
person would be interested in, right?
And so then you're trying to
make their life a little bit
easier, whether it be
you're selling something,
or you're trying to give them
information--
in my case,
information that allows them to act
and do their job a little
bit better without
friction, right?
And so at least
for me, it was just building
different reports
that allows them to
do whatever they need.
One thing I did recently--
just I think on Tuesday--
so
I decided last year to
make a Quarto Revealjs
document, so a
slide deck of like--
we call it [? S2G ?]
wrapped, like the
Spotify Wrapped,
where I summarize all the
things that we've done
in the organization.
And it's more than just
a PowerPoint deck because it
actually embeds all
the different widgets and
dashboards. So I use GT with the
interactivity with it. I use
all these different charts from
high charter, and all that.
And it allows people to
interact with stuff and kind of
see everything as a summary.
And it's one of those things
that I got so much good
feedback, like, oh, my
gosh. This is amazing.
And then allows
the folks to see all the
work that we've done.
And so that's one thing
that I kind of created.
And I would encourage
other people to do that,
is to use like Quarto.
You can create an HTML file,
a PDF, or you use the Revealjs
presentation, or you can render
it as a PowerPoint as well.
But it allows you to go from
just routine analysis to
something that's really amazing that
you can share with people
in your community.
RACHAEL: I love that
idea, George, about using
that prior experience that
people may have learned in
sales. And it was
just making me think--
I mean, I was in
sales at Posit before.
But one of my first jobs
was actually working--
a beer cart on the golf course,
and driving around
in the golf cart. And
that in a way was
also a sales job,
but like figuring out different
ways that you could go
out of your way to
create a better customer experience.
Like if somebody mentioned
they like needed sunscreen,
like going to grab that,
and bringing it out to them.
And so it was just kind
of making me think about when
you're serving these insights as
well and like figuring out
the best way to share
that information.
So your end user has the
best experience possible.
I always love being able
to tie-in like past roles like
that, and lessons
learned. But RM,
I saw you had a comment
on that thread, too.
So I was curious if you wanted
to add anything on that.
RM: Hi, thanks. No,
not a whole lot to add,
but just wanted to say that
sales skills come up in surprising ways.
You might have the most
wonderful piece of analysis,
but you can't convey that
to your stakeholders.
That's essentially worthless.
So it's important to remember,
no matter how cool your code
is, or how powerful
your analysis is,
you still have to
sell the thing.
I know the sale sometimes
is downplayed a little bit, but
it's an important
skill to have.
- Absolutely.
SEAN: Oh, yeah, for sure. I've
noticed that
firsthand, where yeah,
you can have the fanciest
models or anything like that,
but unless you can surface
it to them in something that's
meaningful to them, it's
exactly at that point,
where you can have--
if it lives--
was it--
I think it was David
Robinson, right?
If it lives on your
laptop, it's essentially useless, right?
You need to ship it or
send out something so that people can
actually see it or appreciate
it, right? Because like yeah,
it's great on your
computer on the code.
But
will people actually be
able to use it, right?
It's cool that
you know about it,
but you want to share it
with everyone else, right? So yeah.
RACHAEL: Absolutely Alan,
I see you had a question.
You wanted to jump in here?
ALAN: Yeah. Hey,
everybody. Sean,
I'm really curious about
how you figured out--
as the first data role
in the org, how did you,
and your leaders,
and your peers figure out
what success would look like for
you? Because on one
hand, you've got this--
you've got some autonomy.
You can do [? PSCs. ?]
At some point, you need
to figure out like,
does that get formalized into
like, am I
successful at my job?
And I'm wondering what that
process was like for you.
How did you get
agreement on? Like, OK,
I think this is what I
do now. And people are
happy with that. What
was that process like?
How did you figure that
out organizationally?
SEAN: So I think my role has
evolved over time at [? S2G. ?]
And at first, it's just
that we were trying to--
we had all this information, right?
We wanted to be able to--
because at the end of
the day, technically,
for the bottom
line for [? S2G ?]
is like being able to invest
in innovative companies, and then hopefully,
being able to generate market returns for
the fund at the end of the day.
And so for us, it
was clear, like, hey,
are we driving value for
our portfolio companies?
Because if they're
successful, then in the end,
we'll be successful. And so
it was clear for us, is being
able to identify let's say,
investors that we would want
to co-invest with or other
companies, right?
So it was clear
from there. Like,
if I'm able to identify
investors or companies that are
relevant to us, then therefore,
it will help the bottom
line of the organization.
And so
in terms of how
I'm successful,
so if I'm able to
identify or create different models that
allows us to find
out a company that's a diamond
in the rough, or an investor,
or someone that we may not
have interacted otherwise,
we allow them to
find them by doing analysis,
and things like that.
And therefore, that's how at least
for me, I was successful, right?
And so one way to do that is
to be able to of interview the
different stakeholders, not
necessarily your manager per
se, right? You get guidance
from them. But then you interview
stakeholders, identify
their pain points, right?
It's like, oh,
every time--
I'm scrambling right before my meeting
to find a talking points to
whoever I'm meeting with, right? So
I was like, OK, let's take that,
take the different data
sources using the contextual knowledge
of the different data sources
that we have. So for us,
we use Salesforce,
other data sources,
trying to integrate them,
and then provide a proof of
concept, or whatever.
And then you drive value there
because then you're able to say, like,
remember when you went to me
and you said I have trouble
figuring out what I'm going to
talk to about with this person.
I'm able to provide
that. Therefore,
I give them something
that they like.
And that's how you can kind
be successful in that regard,
at least for me.
Yeah.
- Just to follow up a
tiny bit, was there anybody who, again,
as the first role of the kind,
was there anybody who thought
you were going to be doing
something different? And you
had to reconcile like, oh,
no, I think it's this--
SEAN: Yeah.
ALAN: --and then
figure it out together?
- For sure, yeah. I think
yeah. We had different tools.
And then I think for me, as
I knew what I wanted to do.
But then sometimes you can't do
that because you need like the data
foundation there, right? You
have duplicate accounts. You have--
there's so much things that you
need to cleanse and to be able
to run the cool, fancy models,
which I would love to do.
But the thing is that sometimes
the data is not there.
It's not clean. So
it's like getting--
I think for me, it's like
you create the PoC, and then you-- because you
know what you need to do
in terms of cleaning the
data, get the data sources,
and actually make it
so that it's usable.
So that you can do
it relevant analysis.
So you kind of give them
a nugget that they would like.
And then on the back end,
you kind of fix stuff and
make it cleaner so that
you can actually make more
feature rich PoCs. But yeah,
definitely it's a struggle, right?
A,
Getting the buy-in to get the
tools to be able to do the
thing that they want,
and then kind of getting
the buy-in from them. But yeah,
it's definitely
a struggle. So--
ALAN: Thanks.
SEAN: But then you have autonomy.
I had a lot of autonomy.
So that's like the pros and
cons of like being on a big
team versus being
the solo contributor.
ALAN: Yeah. Thanks.
RACHAEL: I know you mentioned
in one of the answers before,
like trying to advocate for
tools when you already have
something like a BI tool. But
I was wondering, do you also work
alongside with the BI tools?
Or are there any
use cases with that?
- Yeah. So what
I've done recently--
so
we had some BI tools before. And
but then what we didn't have was--
because sometimes
those tools require
essentially more or
less model data layers,
where it's like pretty clear.
Like when you're
querying from this,
you feel confident in the
data that you're pulling from in
terms of the rows,
and things like that.
But
what I had to do is
I had to create ETL pipelines.
So it's just getting data
from our raw data sources,
transforming them,
and modeling them so
that they're actually usable,
and then that actually feeds
our BI tools downstream.
And so at least for me,
we use Posit Connect to
have scripts that take the data,
do the thing, and then send
it back to our data warehouse.
And then from there, our
BI analysts can take the data,
and do whatever they need
to do, and feel confident about
it, rather than pulling
from the raw logs.
We're able to just point to
we call it a model data layer,
right? And so then
you know confidently,
with high confidence
that what you're
displaying is accurate, right?
So it's not like we're trying
to replace one another.
We live in harmony.
So I'm able to take the data,
clean it, and then run my
own analysis. But then other
people, like other not
power users that can use it
to run analysis on themselves and
not have to worry about is
this correct or not. So, yeah.
RACHAEL: Thank you.
Frank, I see you had a
question a bit earlier.
Want to jump in here?
- Hey, Sean. Thanks for
all your insights so far.
You started talking
about modeling.
And you mentioned like building
a model and finding the gems
that wouldn't be
seen otherwise.
And it got me wondering a
lot of this conversation has been
focused on sales,
or like how you pitch
data science in the value,
and how you get information to
the right people at the right
place at the right time.
The question popped
into my head.
If you had to ballpark it,
this is not a super
quantitative answer I'm looking
for, but I'm curious,
if you look back,
what would you say
you attribute your success to
like 50% 50%? Is it that
the sales and the operations and how
you delivered data science
to your organization versus
the modeling and the
statistical rigor
that you do kind of
like behind the scenes?
SEAN: In terms of how--
where do I spend my
time or in terms of
what metrics, sorry?
FRANK: Yeah. No, like what
do you attribute your success to?
SEAN: Oh.
- It sounds like you've
been pretty successful in your role.
So if you had to look back,
and reflect, and say, like, oh,
my success, right,
I do a lot of delivery,
and like selling
to the organization versus--
SEAN: Yeah.
- Yeah. The--
SEAN: Yeah. So I would say--
it
was a struggle at
the beginning, right?
Like there's no doubt about
it, of getting all the
data getting the model
and then we like--
what I did was I was able to--
I would say maybe spent like
I don't know, 75% of the time
getting the value in the sense
that getting the nugget of information.
But it was in like a
colab notebook, right?
So I had this machine
learning pipeline.
And it was essentially, white
glove service of like, Sean,
give me the top 100
investors for this company, or whatever,
right? And so I would do
the analysis and run that stuff.
But then they were
like, oh, you know what?
I want someone that's going
to write a $10 million check.
So then I have to go
in and change it, change it, change
it. So then what I ended
up doing was like, OK,
this is not scalable. We
need to productionalize this to a
PoC, like a
Streamlit application, right?
So it's like a
Python app, web app.
They can kind of do whatever
they want, change the
parameters, do it.
It's self-service.
But
I couldn't do that until I
had like the foundation of the
model, so to speak. So it's
a ton of time went into that,
that was not a good use of
time in the sense of tweaking
every parameter for them.
And so then I was like, OK,
let's create a web application.
And then that was a
beast in and of itself.
But then once that's up
and running, you're kind of smooth
sailing from there.
So it's like 75%.
And then the other 25% for
me was creating a web application
or some type of widget thing
that the end unit or the
business unit could use to be
able to do whatever they want.
And I call it productionalizing
it because it's like--
it's no longer in a notebook,
but it's an actual app, right?
And then another caveat is
like the whole deploying.
Like when you're in the
enterprise, you can't just--
I would love to just
deploy it in GitHub,
and make it open to the world.
But because it's proprietary
information, you have to--
that's another, like,
a security thing,
getting buy in
from your IT people
because that's a whole beast
if you're in a big organization.
You can't just like you have
to go through all these approvals
right. So that's another issue as
well. And I can talk about it
when I got Connect,
right? Because I'm not
a Linux admin.
And so I had to kind of deploy
it and learn all that stuff as well,
and to be able to
deploy it within.
So I can just send
a link to our internal connect
server,
and then anyone in the org
can access the web application easily.
So if you don't
have the enterprise constraints,
it's actually not nearly as
bad as I'm describing it.
So there's plenty of ways to
deploy stuff freely and within GitHub.
But
there's a huge amount of time
building it a little bit for
creating the proof of concept,
like the web application,
and then you have to deploy it.
But then after that,
it's smooth sailing because you
just update it, and push it,
and that's why I kind of
split it up like that.
FRANK: Awesome.
It reminds me of when people say
like if I had x amount of hours,
I would spend 90% of that time
understanding the problem.
SEAN: Oh, yes.
- You're doing that.
You're understanding the problem.
And then once you get that,
and you invested all that,
like building the thing
is relatively easy.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, definitely.
So a lot of it is
understanding the problem, for sure. Yeah.
FRANK: Cool.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NANCY: I have a question.
How do you bring people--
I had a client who was
convinced that these bond
metrics were just a
few calculations in Excel.
And it wasn't it.
It was a big deal.
How do you bring people along
who are really uninformed?
- Yeah. So I think it
is tricky, right? I think sometimes
you'll see--
at least for me,
you'll run an analysis.
And then it'll be almost
like confirmation of like, oh, yeah,
I knew that all along,
right? But like sometimes,
at least for me,
we'll have someone--
I'll list that investor that
the managing director had knew
about, but it wasn't off
the top of their head.
And then for them they, like, oh,
wow, that is interesting, and then that's
relevant to us. But in terms
of different calculations, yeah, I think
in your field is
there instances in which a
value or some type of piece of
information that surfaced
that wouldn't necessarily be
remembered off the
top of their head. Or
do you think it's just more
of an understanding of what's the
nuts and bolts of how
you get to that answer?
NANCY:
I think it was I think
it was it's like calculate prices,
and yields, and duration, and
what happens if you change
the sensitivity to yield changes,
and prices. So it isn't stuff
off the top of the head.
Maybe now that I've done it, it'll
be more on top of my head.
- Yeah.
NANCY: But
he ended up stiffing me and
not paying me at all. So--
- Oh, no.
NANCY: I was really
pissed. Did an R markdown,
had the code for
him, everything.
- Ah, jeez, that's
a bummer. I'm sorry.
NANCY: Yeah, well--
so I want to get
better. So it's like
the whole thing was
convincing him that doing this work
was more complicated than he thought.
- Oh, OK.
NANCY: That's what--
That's what I need the skill--
That's where I didn't do well.
- Oh, no.
I'm sorry about that.
Yeah, sometimes I think
in order to
find that
ability to impress the folks is
sometimes you kind of show what
is the normal route or the path
of in which they give their
answers, and then
you show yours.
NANCY: OK.
- But in your case, it's
a little bit tricky or almost like--
yeah, almost like a chart,
right? It's like here's
how you normally do it, this
is how long it takes. Here's how
my approach will take. It's
more accurate, cheaper, better,
faster, whatever, right?
And then--
NANCY: OK.
SEAN: --at least allows
them to see that.
For me,
on my end of your things.
I'll say like, oh,
I helped automate a process
that would take our analyst
maybe 30 hours of work.
And I ran the
script. And it just--
it runs. So then I can say
I'm saving that organization,
let's say, 120 hours every year
that they can do other things, right?
NANCY: Yeah.
SEAN: And through codification.
So that's how at
least you almost
take the numeral
approach and quantify
of what you're doing to
sell yourself or what you're doing
to provide the customer
value
is what I found.
NANCY:
And part of the story
was to convince somebody that having
reproducible research
is a good idea.
- That's right.
NANCY: As opposed for
a few calculations.
So that's another
thing to sell.
SEAN: Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
NANCY: Yeah. Thank you.
RACHAEL: And so have a--
[INAUDIBLE], you had
a question about--
like a follow-up to Nancy's
question? But also some
thoughts to share here,
do you want to jump in?
No worries if you prefer
to post in the chat.
But I just wanted to let you
know Nancy looks like a lot of
people weighing in
the chat as well.
NANCY: OK. [CHUCKLES]
RACHAEL: [INAUDIBLE]
[CHUCKLES]
I also wanted to add
to still let everybody know
if I miss anybody's questions in
the chat, I don't have
my Posit co-host here--
co-hosts here today.
So just feel free to raise
your hand if there was anything I
missed so that I know. But
thank you so much.
I see Darren, you
just asked a question.
Do you want to jump in?
DARREN: Oh, I was not
expecting that quick response.
RACHAEL: Oh, sorry. Just
thought it first. [CHUCKLES]
DARREN: Sean, I was
curious, you had mentioned
in your discussion--
your experience
working with IT and
having to do your
own ETL pipelines,
being the solo data scientist
in your organization,
and that can be lot or
just an individual person,
especially someone kind of
starting out in data science.
So I was kind of wanted
to know more about your
path, and understanding
who to talk to,
and how to get the resources
you needed to be effective and
do what you want to accomplish?
SEAN: Yeah. Are you asking more
of like how I implemented Posit
Connect and Workbench
within the or just in--
- I mean, not necessarily. It's
just that as a data scientist,
there's so many things that
an individual feel like they have
to learn. And on top of that,
there is this IT side of things
that they may not be familiar with,
and just understanding how data pipelines
work, or how data flows work,
and that's a whole other area
that some data scientists
may not be exposed to.
- Yeah. No, so truthfully,
I think I was kind of
self-taught. And so I
didn't know any better.
So a good example is
learning how--
OK, so I have data that's
like duplicate in Salesforce,
like how can I make it
so I can't dedupe it easily, right?
And so then I created
some scripts that
would dedupe it on
a nightly basis.
But then to your point, I
need to be able to, let's say,
I have Connect or some type
of process to automate it, right?
Making sure you have buy
in from your IT folks, and
sometimes with organizations,
you are really restricted,
right? To be able to
even access the database.
It's like sometimes you
can't even get that, right?
And at least for me,
I was fortunate enough in that
we were building out our Cloud
Infrastructure. And so I had a
little bit of a hand in that.
But by no means knew
like what was up?
I think I talked about in
my Connect talk for Posit that I
was trying to
update the server,
and I totally worked the image.
And so luckily, I backed it up.
And so right now our production
image is like the RStudio
Connect back up. That's what
we use in production now.
Because I didn't
know any better.
And so it's just I think it's
having that mentality to
be able to move
quickly, and to iterate,
and then know that you're
going to make mistakes.
But then I think it's
highly dependent on your
IT infrastructure, and
then being communicative, right?
So sometimes their job is
to make sure everything's secure,
and to not
have data leakage, or
anything like that.
And so making sure that you're
on the same team, right?
To be like, hey, look, we're
on the same team.
We're trying to provide
value to the organization,
and understand what
are their concerns,
and then that you're
not going rogue
because what I've experienced
is that that's not fun for
anyone, right?
But in terms of for my
experience in IT, I think we
had some consultants
that helped us
spin things up,
and then making sure that
you had weekly or monthly meetings
during the implementation phase so that
everyone knew what was going on.
And then as you
work with different
departments, you kind of
earn that trust, right?
And then trust, I think,
at least in the enterprise
that I've experienced helps you get
way further than trying
to do it all on your own.
But I think it is kind
of highly dependent,
but that's the
experience that I've had
that's worked out well.
Definitely hiccups,
though. So--
- Thanks, Sean.
SEAN: Yep
RACHAEL: Thank you.
So I've had this come
up a bit recently.
But I think sometimes
people will see
stories about data science,
and huge companies,
or teams with tons of data
scientists, and think that's so
far from something that could be
possible for my team if we
have one person
or three people.
Some of my favorite stories
are when I get to hear about
superpowers that Connect
gives smaller teams.
But this does not have to
be a Connect focus at all.
I'm just curious if you could
share with us some of the use
cases where you think people
could start making an impact
right away, if they're
a smaller team.
SEAN: Yeah. So I think for
me, being able to host web
applications, whether
it be Streamlit, Shiny,
or other
flask applications securely because that's
like a big hurdle withinN--
at least for me is like I
can't share it publicly, right?
And so one of the quick wins
for me is being able to host
whether it'd be
a Quarto Document
or like our iHost
Oh, look at Apple,
like doing all the little
things. This is like the--
look at that. See? Yeah,
I'm sorry. [LAUGHS]
It enables it.
So it allows you to be able to
host things quickly,
and so that people can
access it in a secure environment.
And then you were asking--
sorry about Connect--
RACHAEL: Yeah. No,
I guess I was saying
like not necessarily Connect specific,
but just some of the
business use cases where people could
start helping to make
an impact right away.
SEAN: Yeah.
-
I think it's helpful sometimes
even if we're all working
across different industries to just
get an idea of ways people
are impacting the
business. And--
- Yeah.
RACHAEL: Yeah.
- Yeah. So a good example
is someone creating basically like I
was helping one of
our analysts out by--
I made a way to--
like a pivot table,
essentially, but like,
where they just upload
whatever CSV that they want.
And it automatically
would do it for them.
It was like a quick thing that
I did for them that made their
life so much easier.
And it would take me time
to do it. I was like,
I don't want to repeat
myself over and over.
So then I basically have
and still to this day.
It's like this little
pivot table thing that will
automatically do
whatever they need to do,
whether it'd be copying
photos for people.
It's just like a little small
toy example that does one thing.
And it's actually
quite helpful, right?
Because then it
frees up my time,
makes them a little bit easier.
It's one of those
things that I think--
it doesn't have to be
complex because I think--
even I thought so.
I wanted to have the most
sophisticated app that has all the--
it's like a Ferrari, right?
But you don't need that.
You just need something
simple, right?
If it does one thing, and
it does it well and robustly,
people will begin to use it
over and over and over, right?
And that's--
it's so funny.
It's like I was so proud
of this app that I made,
but it's like the simple
thing, like the pivot table.
It's like people like that,
right? And it's like, whatever.
It's cool. It did not
take me nearly as long.
But sometimes it's those little
small things that it does it
well. And that's what can get people
really excited about
whatever you're producing.
- I love that. How do you find
out what those things are,
that are taking people way
longer than it should or the
opportunities to help somebody?
- Yeah.
So I think it's just one
of those things where it's like
pattern recognition where
someone has come to you more
than three times to do this
one thing because you do it well.
It's very simple,
whether it be deduping,
or looking up, or aggregating.
So for us, we want to aggregate
our quarterly metrics or
KPIs. And so I do that a
couple of times, just like, you know what?
Maybe we should make this
into a little self-service
application, so that they can
kind of do whatever they want.
They can kind of tweak things,
and then they'll be
able to get out--
the analysis that they need.
And so it's just kind of that--
it's another David
Robinson thing.
Don't do it more than
three times, right?
They'll create a function.
But in this case,
if you do something maybe you
create a Shiny app or whatever
app that can help them do
whatever they need to do more efficiently.
Yeah.
RACHAEL: Cool.
Thank you. Kevin,
I see your comment
here in the chat
about having a repository
of these simple apps.
Would you mind just sharing
a little bit more about what
you'd like to see there? Are
you thinking like for example, companies or--
- Yeah. No, I was just thinking
that I think that's a
great, like the pivot table thing. I
think there are these
things that non-power
users
end up having trouble doing.
And across lots of industries,
it's probably the same.
There's probably a handful of
tasks that people across all
industries are doing in Excel
that could be done with
a nifty web app.
And
yeah, I mean, it might be--
yeah, I was just thinking
it would be cool if
an organization like Posit,
who has access to all of us, you
know? If somehow--
yeah, I'm not sure how we'd
prioritize them because it
wouldn't be helpful if you have
a library of like 1,000 web apps
that do like all sorts of crazy things.
But if somehow it was curated
really well, then--
like for example,
this pivot table app that
Sean's talking about,
we could probably all use that.
And if it's like a
Shiny app or something,
everyone with a Posit server
could just download it from
GitHub, and spin it up,
and try it.
So yeah,
that was the idea. But
again, it would take some curation,
which would be tricky.
But it could be valuable
if it's done right.
- Yeah.
RACHAEL: Yeah. I love it.
SEAN: Yeah.
- Yeah. I'm learning
from all of you.
And when we're talking about
building business cases,
I need to have these examples,
where now I can say, look.
Kevin from the FDA
asked about this.
KEVIN: [LAUGHS]
RACHAEL: [INAUDIBLE]
go do it.
So but seriously,
if there are different apps
like this or examples that you
all are thinking of, or
you're like, oh, I have one.
I maybe could contribute.
That would help me in building
a case for something like this.
So I started a
thread in the chat,
if anybody wants to
comment in there.
OK. Awesome. Let me jump to
scrolling up some of
the questions. So RM,
I see you asked a question
about working with IT.
Do you want to jump
in here and ask that?
RM: Sure. Thanks.
Just following up on the thread
that was mentioned earlier,
I was wondering if you
have any tips or tricks,
or things that work for you
and talking to a common problem
that I've seen is IT doesn't
really talk data science.
And data science doesn't
probably talk IT.
Do you have to learn
key concepts, like what is a
server? How do you secure
it? Like basic stuff like that?
That you may or may not know?
Or conversely, do
you have to teach
IT here? This is what
ETL, is what it does.
Here's why data is not clean.
I'm curious to know
what tips and tricks
you might suggest or things
that might have worked for you.
- Yeah. I think for me,
understanding whatever
protocol that they use.
At least for us, we--
remember I'm not like a cloud
security guy.
Learning that we use Okta,
and making sure that
all the things that we
had were secured via SSL
when we were spinning up
Posit Connect within our organization,
making sure that we had Okta
authenticate everything,
and making sure that using the
keywords or buzzwords that they identify with.
Because to your point, I
don't necessarily speak IT natively,
all the security.
And then conversely,
they don't speak data
science necessarily, right?
But to make sure,
it's like, hey,
I understand this is a high
concern for you. And I share
that as well. And here's
what we've done to address that.
Does this sound
reasonable to you?
And so like almost meeting them
where they are is quite helpful,
even though you may not speak
exactly the same language,
right? So like my understanding
with Okta and all that is
we're using that as the
gatekeeper to authenticate
everything. And once you
use that and you're compliant,
then the IT people were
relieved, or like,
OK, this is good.
But then I think your mileage
may vary depending on the
organization. I don't
know how it's like-- like
with the FDA, right? I
don't know things like that.
In terms of how
it is. So it is
context dependent.
But in terms of the general
tips that I found that helped
me out was like
communicating, meeting them.
Even if you know it's secure,
like making sure that
they understand that you're not
trying to go around them
to do that.
RM: Thank you.
That makes sense.
SEAN: Mm-hmm.
- Thank you. I see a
few anonymous questions.
I want to go over
to as well. And
one was
it says thanks a lot.
Can you share how you tackled
data silos and access company data sources?
Did you handle it alone or
seek support from other teams?
SEAN: Yeah. So data silos
can exist. I think that's--
for me,
it was not necessarily data
silos because all of our stuff
is in the cloud. So
we use Google Cloud--
Google Cloud platform for
our stuff. But for me,
data was siloed and the
brains of the business unit.
And so what we've done
was do informational interviews where you
go tag along with them right to see
how do they go about doing their job.
And so by going to
let's say the business development team
or the investment team,
and kind of shadowing them,
you understand
wither their pain
points, or what
you can do as a data scientist
to help make their job easier, right?
And so that's kind of what
I had to do to understand
that, oh, they're really
looking for this information.
And it is there. It's just
maybe not easily accessible to
them, right? And so
that's how you do that. OK,
like, at least for me, all the data
is in like BigQuery, and all the--
because we feed everything
into the data warehouse.
And then we do all the
transformations and send it
back to a clean layer, right?
But in order for me to know
what to extract, because
there's so much raw data,
you almost have to understand
what is the business trying to
achieve, right?
Because sometimes I've
done things all the time,
where I do stuff that's what
I think is like addresses what
they need, but it's not
exactly what they want.
It's like they may ask for A, B,
C, but they really need D, E, F, right?
But you don't realize that
until you talk to them.
Even though they say I want A,
B, C, they really need D, E, F.
And you don't get that
until you're actually kind understand things
because we are working
with everything. But
that's what I've noticed, is
you deliver what they ask for,
but not necessarily what they
need. If that makes sense.
So it's like you only get
that by kind of iterating,
understanding where data may
be or whatever problem that
they're trying to solve
in terms of a silo.
And then you'll be able to
integrate it that way. But I
realize that may not be
the case because some
enterprises have
true data silos,
where it's like a
totally different.
Server 1 is on prem,
one is in the cloud,
one you don't have access
rights to, if it's health care
data. So I can't speak to that. But
I can at least speak to my experience.
RACHAEL:
How do you figure out more
quickly what they actually need
if it's not what they
told you they wanted?
SEAN: Yeah.
Because I was in grad school,
I'm used to working late night
hours and just working on it
for just brute force
figuring it out.
But what I had to realize
when I pivoted the industry is being
able to iterate quickly, to be
able to show them like a janky
looking report or
with some number.
It's like, is this
right? Is this not right?
Is this in the ballpark?
And then getting feedback or
directionality because I do like that,
like the Shiny well
polished application. But it's like
it'll get to that thing
where you work on it,
but then it's like they're like
this is not what I wanted, right?
And so you're much better
off showing something that's really
rough, but it's somewhat
tangentially relevant to them.
And then iterating again,
then to take all the time,
make it super
beautiful looking,
but it's like not the values
or the information that they want, right?
So that was kind of one thing
I had to kind of unlearn when I
was in graduate school
to the industry is like
to make sure you're
getting feedback from them. Yeah.
RACHAEL: That's
great. Thank you.
SEAN: Mm-hmm.
- Alan, I think you have
a question in the chat,
also a comment. So I'll
just have you jump in.
I wasn't reading it all yet.
- Oh, no. I don't
want to be the--
my question is more
of a comment guy.
- No, no, not at all. I just--
can't use both
parts of my brain.
- I think I have two
competing things going on in my brain.
One of which is I love the
idea of the pivot table use case and
all it opens up of
making nimble flexible,
ad hoc tools that really
meet a business solution.
And I love that
because it's elegant.
And it's exciting way to work.
And at the same time,
I think it competes with
push back about proliferation of
solutions and
a different avenue of doing
work, which would be like
saying, hey, the analyst has just
got to get better at RBI,
or whatever, right?
And so I'm really curious about what
are the stories to tell that motivate
the kind of work that we all
really, really super love
versus that other story.
And so I'm curious if--
Sean,
if you or if others
have that success story that motivates
that way to work,
as opposed to the-- like,
well, no,
you use the Enterprise Vi
app channel way to work.
Because I think those
are in somewhat tension. Yeah.
- I totally agree. I think
it is for us because
we're a little bit smaller, right?
We don't have that problem yet.
But I can definitely envision
this being something that is if
you have a larger team,
where yeah, to your point,
the analysts or whoever
should get more proficient.
But
at least in my instances, it's
our admin that needs--
that just wants a quick
calculation to get on to do
whatever they need to do.
But I think that's one of
those things where at least for me,
if it's in Connect, you
can look at the usage
metrics, and theoretically, look at
the logs to see like,
oh, maybe this person--
And I think you have a
conversation. It's like, OK,
it seems this is
really valuable to you.
And then you can
kind of address,
like maybe they
need to get better.
But I think you have to
be strategic about that.
You don't want to
be like logging people's activity.
But I think another
instance is let's say you have
a suite of really small toy
shiny apps, or whatever for pivot
tables and all that, you can almost
making that a featured
application that allows them to
do whatever they need to
do. So let's [INAUDIBLE]
they need to pivot. They need
to crop. And they need to,
I don't know, make sure that
the data is not missing.
You can almost package that
into a larger application that
allows them to do that.
But I do I do see your
point about like--
there is a time and a
place to use the Enterprise preferred
business intelligence
tools, right?
And that's tricky, for sure.
ALAN: Yeah.
SEAN: Yeah
- For sure.
SEAN: Yeah.
- Thanks.
-
One anonymous question was can
you share how you developed the
intuition as a data scientist
or statistician to make certain decisions?
- Intuition, yeah, I
think for you [INAUDIBLE]
for me, you get like that
code sensor, like that--
you get the inkling for me
what the business would want, right?
And then from there, it's
kind of testing the water.
So what I do is I
have folks that aren't necessarily the
super senior managers,
but I have the junior level
people that are in the--
working on the business.
And I will send them little
snippets of projects,
works in progress.
And then I almost use them
as a barometer in the right
direction. And then if it
is, then we kind of go there.
So that's like when
I did the [? S2G ?]
wrapped.
I went to a couple of
our associates. And I was like,
hey, what do you
guys think of this?
Does this look and feel right?
Because
sometimes when you're
presenting to management,
if the values are off, they're going to
like, why is this off? Why is this--
right?
And so you go to the
people that are a little bit more
junior and you ask them like,
hey, does this feel right?
Does this seem
right? Does it not?
And what would you want on
the next slide or whatever, right?
And so then you kind of use
them to be able to guide yourself
on producing
different applications or
products, what data products.
- Thank you.
Kevin, I realize I missed a
question from you earlier about
getting feedback from stakeholders. Do
you want to add anything
there or was--
KEVIN: Yeah. Sure.
Yeah, I think it's--
my question really-- what I
wanted to ask like how do you
manage like the kind of
long term vision, right,
when maybe the management
doesn't really know what's possible.
And they--
Yeah,
I find myself in this
position sometimes,
where I'm trying to
figure out how to--
where long term, we want
to prioritize and build things.
But the management doesn't
really know what's possible.
And so it's hard
to get from them,
like what would
they prioritize?
Like yeah,
how do you kind of get
priorities from management
that's not in touch with
what's possible? If
that makes sense.
- No, for sure. I
think what I've done is
I do whatever
is asked of me. So let's
say, it's like the XYZ KPIs, you
do that. But then sometimes
I'll work on a side project.
At least for me,
I was doing like a relational
graph network this year for our
wrap. And I kind
of slipped that in,
as like a little thing was
like, I think this is pretty
cool. They're going to
think it's relevant.
And you do everything. You're
not going rogue, per se.
But you're just adding
that little, oh,
look at this cool thing.
And then you kind of--
and you try to find the most
not shiny, but more like
interesting thing if you can,
and insert it. And then
that will pique their interest,
right? And then they'll
ask you for more.
And then you almost kind
of get that permission to--
oh, that was just something
I spun up last afternoon.
And then they're like,
oh, yeah, let's do that.
So it's kind of like
the indirect way of doing it.
And I'm not advocating for
like disobeying your manager,
or anything like that. But
like what I'm saying is
they may not know
what's possible.
And so what we're trying to
do is show them like, hey,
this might be possible.
Would you like me to spend
more time on this, right?
And you still do
whatever you need to do.
That's the beauty of having
code is you're able to use
something, and recycle
it, and improve it.
But then at the same time,
you can kind of work on
other things, and maybe slip that in,
and then get them to buy in.
And so that's like--
truthfully, that's basically the
journey that I've been
going on, is like I knew
what I wanted to do,
but like there are certain
things that needed to be in
place in order to do that.
So if I wanted to
do a graph network,
I got to make sure the
data is correct, right?
- Yeah.
SEAN: Get some way to surface
it to them, and then do that.
So then you do those things,
and then you kind of slip
it in once all those prerequisites
are met. But--
KEVIN: Yeah.
- [INAUDIBLE]
KEVIN: No. And my
question is less about--
yeah,
giving yourself permission to do
that because I totally get
that. Yeah, you got to do
it, and show them, right?
But it's more like just
really big picture, like
how do you get input on
the vision casting for that when--
you know, because obviously,
you can make your own vision
of what you think this graph
thing. You have a
whole vision for it.
And you can go
forward with that.
And that's awesome.
But ideally,
when you're working
for an organization,
you do want to somehow get
input or some direction from the leadership,
and not just always
be steering them.
- Yeah. No--
KEVIN: Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
I think it's one of those
things where you try to have
that open conversation
with the management,
and where you're
getting, like, oh,
what do you think about next
year us creating an [? S2G ?]
chat bot, or we're using a
long chain LLMs, type stuff.
And they may not necessarily
understand, be like, oh,
a ChatGPT for the
organization, right?
And so then they're like, oh,
yes. We would love that. Right?
And it's almost kind of like it
depends on your relationship with
the management as well. Like
KEVIN: Yeah.
SEAN: [INAUDIBLE]
- No that's really
helpful. Thanks, man.
SEAN: Having a
conversation would be like,
let's just brainstorm
what we call--
at
least my relationship with the
management is like that where
you can kind of hey,
what do you think about
a ChatGPT for the org?
It's going to be a huge
effort. Don't get me wrong.
But like you're
having a conversation.
It's like, is this something
worth pursuing? Is this not?
And then from there,
you kind understand
their priorities as well.
But I acknowledge that it's--
that may not be the case
for some people. I would imagine
FDA, you can't just waltz up
to the administrator, right?
But you know,
trying to understand
and meet with
the decision
makers, and kind ask
them about the vision,
and slip some, you know,
would something like this be useful
or not, is like what I
was thinking. I don't know.
KEVIN: Yeah. I think the
brainstorming approach makes
sense. Yeah, that's
good. Thanks, man.
RACHAEL: Love it. Well,
thank you all so much for
joining us today, and for all
the Hangouts that you've joined us
in 2023. Thank you so much,
Sean, for sharing your experience with
all of us today as well.
- Yeah, thank you
for having me.
RACHAEL: [INAUDIBLE]
everybody--
- Appreciate it.
RACHAEL: Yeah. Wishing
everybody a great holiday.
And we'll see you all
back in the new year.
So we'll be back
on January 11th
with Marianne from TD Bank.
And I've been listening to
a lot of podcasts lately,
where they do their
credits at the end.
And I realize I
don't do that here.
So I do want to say thank
you as well to all the people from
Posit, who make the
Data Science Hangout happen.
You may notice I occasionally
have a different co-host on
helping me. So thank you
to Hannah, Tyler, Robert, Curtis,
and Katherine who will
jump in to do that,
as well as our creative team,
who helps us make sure we
get these recordings up,
and the upcoming speaker list.
So thank you to
Olivia, [? Maya, ?] [? Green,
?]
and Margaret.
But have a great holiday season
and a Happy New Year, everybody.
Thank you.
- Thank you all.
WOMAN: Thank you.
RACHAEL: Bye all.
- OK. OK. OK.